welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown for the
trailer for thor love and thunder which
gets us so lost in chris hemsworth's
eyes like the bluest guys that it's a
bit easy to miss the love and the
thunder which i assume are what thor's
sweet child named her biceps there's so
many cool details hidden in this trailer
so let's punch those tickets to the gun
show and break down this frame by frame
and thanks to true bill for sponsoring
today's video more on them later let's
go
these hands who i once used for battle
now they're about humble tools for peace
i need to figure out
who i am
all right we opened on thor sprinting
through the eras of his life and i'm
pretty sure his youngest self is
actually played by one of chris
hemsworth's real life sons the twins
tristan and sasha awesome to get them in
there and i think this imagery mirrors
the journey of forrest gump a run and
rambler who stumbles through war zones
and prize matches and boats until
turning into a bearded trucker hat
wearing zen master just trying to
reconnect with the woman who got away
women now with tragic health conditions
i may not be a smart avenged jane but i
know what love and thunder is now the
second phase of thor's youth shows his
teenage self wearing thor's classic
costume from the jack kirby comics the
winged helmet the blue pants yellow
boots the montage is a thor surrounded
by flames representing his home of
asgard being burned by certain ragnarok
now the final shot of the trailer shows
thor in the same bird collar i'm
assuming this is new asgard of tonsberg
burning down making this the second time
thor has had to watch an asgard burn but
you know it's not a place of people from
these ashes we cut to a symbol of new
beginnings thor planting a tree except
this is more than a tree it's the handle
of stormbreaker whose ruins on the blade
for storm breaker remember
stormbreaker's handle was made from the
tree branch arm of groot infinity war
now once that arm was severed it ceased
to be part of groot thus why it did not
dust along with him in thanos snap but
years ago i discussed the theory that
thor might replant the handle of
stormbreaker to regrow the yidroso
world's tree after it burned in ragnarok
which might be what vin diesel was
referring to in that 2020 interview with
comicbook.com when he described groot's
return in love and thunder as quote
alpha groot of course thor's gardening
here calls back thanos's move after
retiring at the end of his conquests
when he tilled the soil as he watched
the sun rise on the grateful universe
but in thor's case here i should say
suns because this planet ain't earth as
in the sky behind him is a massive sun
and then two other planets or moons to
its upper left and then a blue glowing
celestial body another light source
behind the tree and then a ringed planet
in the upper right corner and i am
assuming love and thunder will finally
reveal to us the only one of the nine
realms we have yet to see in the mcu
alpheim home of the light elves not of
alf even though he is canon in marvel
comics lore notice the scar over thor's
right eye that's from when hella sliced
out of zion ragnarok it's come a long
way in healing and now both his eyes are
bright blue definitely bluer than they
were before and his prosthetic right eye
has been replaced since ingame perhaps
that could be why he went to alfheim
using the light elves magic to heal
himself both physically and based on
this don draper meditation pose here
spiritually as well now the music of
this trailer is guns of rose's sweet
child oh mine which has lyrics
referencing eyes like the bluest skies
and childhood memories where everything
was as fresh as a bright blue sky axel
rose wrote these lyrics for girlfriend
aaron everly daughter of dawn everly of
the everly brothers whose song all i
have to do is dream just appeared in a
recent promo for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness multiverse of
madness does seem like a story about
parenting love and thunder a story about
being sweet children of the gods now of
course my favorite cover of this guns
and rosa song is the acapella rendition
from step brothers with adam scott and
catherine hahn let's go
flat
it's so flat i can't even i don't even
know you don't even look good while
you're singing the worst thing i've ever
heard
just 1200 a week for voice lessons and
this is what i get okay i'm going to
save it with the solo and we must thank
agatha harkness for singing the key
lyric for this trailer pray for the
thunder in the rain to quietly pass me
by thor is the god of thunder but he's
literally burying the hatchet praying
not for thunder to empower him but to
pass him by because i think the thunder
of love and thunder is truly going to be
brought by the villain gore the
godbutcher and the sweet child of mine
of the song is actually gore's child and
wife who were killed after he prayed for
the thunder and the rain to pass them by
but those prayers were left unanswered
and i just find it interesting that this
trailer ends short of guns and rose's
dark aggressive shift in this song from
the ballad to the where do we go
where do we go where do we go now
as if the darkest is still yet to come
enough of me singing let's move on
alright we see the workout montage
showing how thor lost that weight from
endgame not that he needed to lose it he
wears a trucker hat that reads strongest
avenger a callback to the running joke
of him considering himself the strongest
avenger overhulk and ragnarok voice
activation required strongest avenger
access denied welcome strongest avenger
oh what also when he considers himself
the strongest avenger game i'm the
strongest avenger okay so this
responsibility falls upon me but my
favorite detail about this hat is the
fact that thor used a sharpie to write
this over a different hat that said
something else because it looks like
that hat originally said the mightiest
avengers but he wrote strong over mighty
and then traced over the est in black so
it would look less weird and then he
just said screw it and scribbled out the
s of avengers so it would just be only
one avenger himself actually thor's
whole look here is modeled on vince
d'onofrio's look and adventures in
babysitting when you play the mechanic
dawson whom the girl sarah obsessed with
thor comics thinks is thor an awesome
scene of that movie thor oh thor mighty
god of thunder
who is this kid careful kid don't
embarrass him in front of vanessa so
thor is doing the battle ropes with
these chains from a giant skeleton i was
wondering if this could be another one
of the knit valyrian dwarves like a
prisoner who was left to rot after
thanos slaughtered them but that skull
has an odd shape to it not exactly
humanoid so this might just be another
god whom gore has killed and based on
his poor guy being left in chains maybe
this is someone gore tortured first so
thor uncloaks his new bod and he's
wearing a white tank and red vest and
tight blue pants actually looking a lot
like kurt russell in big trouble little
china make it a bit ironic for ego's son
peter quill to roll his eyes here
actually looks like thor might have
stolen some of peter quill's clothes and
as i pointed out in a past video the
shirt that he's wearing may depict a
yourself connecting the nine realms now
they're saving this planet populated by
these blue skinned locals i think this
actually might be centauri 4 the
homeworld of yondu which would make this
the zatoan tribe in eternals we learned
that one of the past planets that they
helped destroy was called century 6.
everyone in century 6 is going to die
now it's spelled a bit different century
versus centauri but in the thor comics
century 6 is part of the same alpha
centauri star system as century 4. so
i'm wondering if gore the god butcher's
hatred of the gods might have began
because he comes from that century sixth
planet that was destroyed in order to
birth the celestial a god a hatching
that killed his wife and child while he
just happened to be off world which
would make him so angry that he must now
kill all the gods of the cosmic
hierarchy and everyone related to them
including asgardians like thor and
valkyrie and sons of celestials like
peter quill and it could be on this
planet centauri 4 where thor and the
guardians learn the story of a nearby
planet named centauri 6 in their system
with one very pissed off soul survivor
and then we get this full guardians of
the galaxy charge with teenage groot
who's actually been filling out more
there's some more greenery on his head
the nebula mantis quill craglin is there
wearing yondu's yucca arrow fin as he
did in the guardians vol 2 post credit
scene and then rock it and then i assume
drax on the far right but no gamora we
should note after the end game final
battle and quill brain are up on a
screen in that final scene they still
have not found that variant gamora from
2014. the guardians end up leaving
behind thor and korg on a planet that
looks like sakhar as they pilot the
benatar through that hexagonal universal
neural teleportation network grid if
this is the car i'm super excited that
they're returning here because this
might be where they can meet up with
beta ray bill the corbinite past
champion of sakaar and the way they
framed this shot weird empty space on
the left beside thor just really looks
like the shot was framed for three
characters and maybe beta ray bill or
someone else might have been digitally
removed from this trailer you'll notice
how korg has a new look some colorful
pants and a belt buckle in the shape of
a goat head i'm wondering if he might
now work at new asgard which is now a
tourism theme park as the herder of
thor's goats so we take a tour of new
asgard and compared to the colony it
wasn't in game the structures have
evolved from the sleepy town of tonsburg
norway to some taller curved golden
structures like the old asgard had so
either they're starting to truly rebuild
what they once had or they might just be
making a disney version of it to attract
tourists or they might be doing both we
see a flying boat departing the port
carted by thor's goats these are named
this and this not even gonna bother
trying to pronounce it but they mean
teeth bearer and teeth grinder in norse
mythology they are thor's companions
they pull his chariot across the sky and
they're wonderful i'm so glad they're in
this movie on this boat you can see
valkyrie in korg and then up front two
others it looks like thor maybe jane
with them there and i love it there's
the neon sign reading cocktails and
dreams which is the name of the bar that
tom cruise works at at the end of the
1988 movie cocktail the 80s references
are everywhere and i'm loving it now if
you're keeping your fingers crossed that
the beanie baby collection in your mom's
attic is going to regain its value and
all of your money concerns will be gone
our friends at true bill are here to
help take some of the pressure off of
claude the crab and paddy the platypus
true bill is an all-in-one finance
platform that helps you save more and
spend less the personal finance manager
allows you to manage subscriptions lower
bills monitor your credit score and
build your savings all in one place i
really like how easy truebill makes it
to safely and securely identify
recurring charges and cancel unwanted
subscriptions with just a tap it's also
got some nice credit score monitoring
tools to give you a little nudge when
something fishy might be happening not
fishy like bubbles a beanie baby but you
know like scammy truebill helps set
budgets that automatically monitor your
spending by category get friendly
notifications when you've exceeded your
budget and visualize your spend to earn
ratio over time so get started with true
build today by heading to truebuild.com
new rockstars or by clicking the link in
the video's description that's
truebill.com new rockstars then this
glorious shot of olympus a realm similar
to asgard in the marvel comics but the
home of zeus and aphrodite all the other
greek gods the design is just
breathtaking like asgard the land mass
is suspended in space with impossible
gravity water just spilling in the mist
here from these roman style aqueducts
that snake through all the structures in
the lower left it looks like it's open
space and stars out there so who knows
this could all be suspended inside of
another part of a dead celestial like
nowhere's headless body because the
sword carried by gore in this movie is
the same weapon that in the marvel
comics lore be headed nowhere so this
movie may confirm that history you'll
notice a pink purple streak meteors
through this olympus space maybe thor
and his friends arriving or maybe this
is an attack from gore tycho what tt
embraces his our flag means death vibes
with thor on a pirate ship as a woman
swings over to embrace him looking like
the cover of a romance novel if this is
the same setting as the tree meditation
shot earlier this might be a light elf
of alpheim notice how the ship behind
him is being smothered by a kraken could
it be a friend of gargantos could it
just be its own its own thing maybe then
the viking ship sails toward this planet
that i thought was earth but if you look
closely at the surface it looks like it
might be in the process of freezing over
thought it was just a sunrise light
hitting the clouds but it does look like
it's streaking through its atmosphere
faster than the planet is rotating
toward its sun thor stands on the bow
with stormbreaker streaming forward
since stormbreaker remember has the
powers of the bifrost this is how
they're traveling through these
wormholes in space then lightning
streams through the hall of olympus all
this goofy acrobatic display with
pointed lightning bolt ends up until
they are caught as one goofy looking
bolt by zeus played here by russell
crowe at his side are two goddesses
perhaps hera an aphrodite or maybe one
of his many mistresses because this is
zeus all he does is ruin lives across
the hall are other gods of plotting it
looks like the stands are arranged in
boxes with one larger brightly colored
god or goddess in the center and then
there are minions or sub-deities
surrounding them i assume among these
are going to be ares who cameoed and
thor ragnarok is another past champion
of sakhar and most likely hercules
zeus's son a major rival to thor in the
comics who has a ton of arcs let's get
hercules in this movie please and yeah
this all does look a bit cheesy but i
think that's the point because we're
probably gonna see this place just get
wrecked by gore in the opening act like
i'm sorry if you loved zeus and the
other greek gods in the marvel comics
i'll just say don't get too attached
because taiko tt is the same director
who killed the warriors three with a
flick of hella's wrist thor and korg
high five as the text of this section
reads not every god has a plan which
reflects thor's aimless post-avenger
life now but also hearkens to gore's
biggest criticism of the gods of the
marvel universe they have no plan they
let horrible things happen they cast
judgment without explaining the rules by
the end of this film i think we will
find ourselves echoing the words of nick
fury in the comics who whispered to thor
to make him drop me all near gore was
right the one sign of gore's violence in
this trailer at least the corpse of
falagar the behemoth this image taken
directly from jason aaron's godbutcher
storyline artwork by assad ribbik and
thor god of thunder number three when
thor is investigating the deity figures
whom gore has killed even the trickle of
blood coming out of faligar's nostrils
is exactly the same i don't think we've
ever seen a frame of the mcu so
perfectly match a panel in the comics
and i really can't blame them the image
is heart stopping the only difference is
that korg now joins thor on that boulder
so now thor is someone to explain the
terrifying significance of falagar's
death in that comic panel thor explains
how falagar was the patron god of the
galactic frontier who wrestled black
holes just for fun we can also imagine
now for all the ground level people on a
planet and a neighboring star system
just for some [ __ ] to punt his black
hole into your backyard would kill
trillions of life forms then a new shot
of new asgard showing it from the same
angle as when rocket and smart hulk
approached the town and end game on that
winding road now the port has filled
with several cruise liners including one
with the face of volstag member of the
warriors 3 abruptly killed off a van
marks new asgard tours drives down that
road with a logo that features mjolnir
on it now it looks like this movie that
there's going to be a mound in this
tourism destination that displays the
broken pieces of mjolnir as a key
attraction the earth dug out around it
making a kind of pedestal since people
might not be able to move the uru shards
kind of like how disneyland has a sword
in the stone and that will be where jane
foster is empowered as the pieces come
back together valkyrie now sits at the
head of an international summit the sign
of the corner reads renewable energy
conference with art looking like a
series of waterfalls that pour into each
other maybe showing how the asgardians
and the olympians recycle water through
their infinity pool water systems that
seem impossible but probably work on
some kind of asgardian magic currently
you'll notice the representative from
the united states is standing because
that's what we do here we stand so i
wonder if asgardian science magic that
empowers their boats and everything else
in their lives has become a pretty
game-changing energy resource on earth
which would complicate things on
oil-dependent countries like the us that
needs to protect call jobs fracking but
i also like how at this table of
international power players seated in
the guest of honors of valkyrie's left
is new zealand i am pretty sure this is
that type of tc's insistence now
remember in spider-man no way home an
international news ticker read political
turmoil in new asgard this could be what
that was referring to also in the
corners of this room notice two armed
guards with berets an interesting leg
armor these could be the new einheri r
of new asgard on earth remember those
are the guards that protected asgard now
they got a new taran take on their gear
now valkyrie meanwhile looks bored on
her throne an office chair with
asgardian printing along the back she's
chewing food on some skewer and above
her is a sigil which i assume will be
her variant of odin's symbol maybe
turned upside down or something like
that now to the left meek is there
wearing a business suit prepping a drink
for valkyrie cocktails and dreams baby
but notice how valkyrie is sitting right
between two doors hair and dom for the
men in the women's restrooms but right
in the middle it's just some fun framing
reflecting now valkyrie is really a
character who defies gender norms then
another shot of olympus with a huge zoo
statue ahead now on that walkway is korg
and thor and then another red caped
figure i assume jane foster you'll
notice statues on the left and the right
depicting other gods on the left maybe
aphrodite on the right that could be
artemis goddess of the hunt on to the
next clip
[Applause]
[Music]
not me
what
just listening
all right we got a better shot of the
guardians here quill drax nebula mantis
rocket and groot and mantis has this
interesting chip on her forehead now
which are connected to her antennae
perhaps a way of amplifying her
emotional sensing abilities thor is just
trying so hard to make will love him
because all the other people he loves in
his life are dead when you think about
it he refuses to break eye contact just
like how he stared peter directly in the
eyes on the benatar at the end of end
game and you can see now in the close-up
that thor has regrown his braid that he
used to have in the earlier movies
before his head was shaved in ragnarok
and before he let himself go and in game
i love how the title logo has this
metallic look to it like an 80s rock
band just metal pieces sliding into
place in a diamond shape to form the o
which also reflects the angular text of
norse runes then on to the last clap
oh baby so the reforged mjolnir flies
into the hand of jane foster with
natalie portman returning after throw
the dark world in an adaptation of jason
aaron's mighty thor run that follows
jane as a cancer patient who wields
mjolnir after the case of gore made thor
want to drop the hammer considering
himself unworthy now powering up into
lady thor allows jane to escape her
sickness but whenever she returns to
normal her chemo is reset setting up
this fascinating and tragic storyline
for the character now how did this
happen well the movie's official
description says jane foster who to
thor's surprise inexplicably wields his
magic hammer mjolnir as the mighty thor
that suggests that whatever causes
hammer to reforge was some mysterious
magic that thor is not familiar with now
it's been implied that infinity stones
left cosmic radiation coursing through
the universe and in the case of jane
foster who is possessed by the reality
stone ether that radiation could have
been the cause of her cancer as well as
what now triggers the hammer to
reassemble it's also possible that the
multiverse could have caused this
reassembly in some way like she comes
from another universe or the hammer
comes from another universe and more
will be revealed in a future trailer
after doctor dr strange's multiverse
madness comes out i have a feeling that
the hammer's return will have an
in-universe answer like either residual
reality stone radiation or some hidden
will and testament clause from frigate
or odin that includes jane foster in
that worthiness charm like whoever
wields us emma if he be worthy shall
possess the powers of thor also
underclaws whoever that current bearer
loves the most can can also wield it
sometimes now compared to the shot of
hella destroying the hammer and ragnarok
the cracks of mjolnir are now spread
apart with bigger chunks but notice how
the golden end is facing upward now i
think we're looking at the other side of
it i just like this look better than a
more capillary splintered look because
now from a distance you can still make
out the individual cracks of that hammer
this reveal of natalie portman as lady
thor works really well better than i
thought it would and honestly marvel
studios really needed this to work and
they totally pulled it off but they used
a few interesting visual tricks to do it
now yes jane is definitely beefed up
here i'm sure natalie portman put on
quite a bit of muscle but i wouldn't be
surprised if they did that classic tom
holland muscle enhancement there but she
does need to be beefed up yet the focus
of the shot is not on her muscle
definition her shoulders her traps her
neck forearms they're all covered they
also cover her face with the helmet all
to avoid that uncanny valley effect
where we might see natalie portman's
iconic face but on a different body
which would just kind of freak us out
instead the focus is on mjolnir a
striking unusual image to see it put
together again and that is what guides
us into the shot and then we move
directly from mjolnir to jane's eyes
which are locked directly on us see
there is a narrative to this reveal as
opposed to just barfing in a visual
effect in a trailer and we get to pull
it apart there's a story here our eyes
are guided by the emotion of this moment
now behind both jane and thor it looks
like the town of new asgard is being
attacked by these weird-looking dark
tentacled creatures and then to the left
behind jane whatever this is is flashing
some sharp teeth gore's weapon all black
has some connections to the symbiotes in
marvel lore it was a weapon created by
the symbiote deity of no and we did see
in spiderman no way home that a piece of
venom is left in the boundary of the mcu
so could we be looking at some kind of
venom creature attacking new asgard look
i don't know i don't think venom can
appear in an mcu movie without it being
a sony co-production the way spider-man
no way home was so i don't know if
they'll keep that symbiote backstory but
if you think about it the way that dane
whitman's sword the ebony blade also had
a black shape-shifting essence to it
when he reached out to it that could be
the same way gore's blade works making
it a kind of poison not a venom a poison
that rots a target from the inside out
that could be how we got that chained up
skeleton it could be a poison that
thematically parallels the way cancer
attacks the body which would make jane's
conflict with gore super important and
super symbolic for her in this movie
support us by checking out our merch
options like our moon night inspired
tomb of the moon god shirt and new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter eaboss following
your rockstars subscribe to rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you